[Music]
all right we're broadcasting from
edinburgh texas right near mcallen
and i'm joined on stage former president
trump and texas governor greg abbott
right this is a town hall we're gonna
have some questions ma'am uh
welcome to the program thank you what's
your first name my name is janet brown
and i live in edinburgh
welcome and thank you for being with me
um i
am hispanic i am
i actually came from nicaragua central
america
i'm very familiar with central america
because we
i lived there two years in honduras and
the rest of nicaragua
i came to the united states from 1960
i won't tell you my age but but anyway
i came here legally and it is really sad
to see what's going on at our borders
here
question my question is president trump
what long-term damage and destruction
will biden's
open borders agenda do to the country
and what is it costing law abiding
u.s taxpayers so it's a
you know very fair question and i know
you know that answer probably as well as
everybody in this room
it's incalculable how
bad this is where you have not hundreds
of thousands but millions of people
storming into our country
some of them as we discussed are from
prisons and they're bad and they're
murderers and all of the things that i
said before
it is there's no way to judge that kind
of damage and
you know getting them out is a is an
ordeal
and all sorts of things will happen it's
going to be very hard
but i will say this it has to be stopped
now this can't go till
2022. they all say oh we're going to win
congress this can't go they have to do
something immediately
people are storming up you look at some
of these caravans where they have 15 and
20 and 25 000 people
and you don't know who's in those
caravans and dotted in those caravans
are some of the worst people on earth so
it's a tremendous cost and it's also
monetarily a tremendous course you're
talking about trillions and trillions of
dollars sean can i add to it
yeah janet what's happening here is the
erosion of the social fabric of the
united states of america the united
states of america was built
upon the rule of law and what the body
administration is doing is not enforcing
the rule of law
the first thing that happens for all the
people that are letting in they know
they are getting away with violating the
rule of law that will erode the united
states of america
it must be stopped i agree with you
let me let me pick up on and thank you
ma'am thank you for calling
trump thank you
i don't know governor if we should take
it personally it wasn't viva uh
you know just him we'll just leave the
stage and it'll be all trump
let's talk a little politics europe
governor in
in 2022 um i like president trump
i'm open with my opinions all the fake
news journalists they say they're
objective we know they're not
they have an agenda but you've done a
great job for the state
i support your your nomination as the
president has
i guess the question is let's talk about
2022
really good chance you will be
re-elected house could turn republican
and then we looked at the states where
senate races are
i don't think it could be a bigger
bellwether florida georgia
north and south carolina new hampshire
uh
we have ohio wisconsin and arizona
those are all states we're very familiar
with how important
is it for the republicans to take those
key senators so i think without
weak republican rhino leadership you'd
win
every one of them everyone dotted in
there are people that
you almost would say don't like
this country they don't like the
republican party
with strong rep republican leadership in
charge of those states you'll win every
one of them
without that you won't governor i'm
going to give you this is your last
segment with us
what it means to you
to be the conservative governor of texas
listen even in texas remember this texas
is also the state of people like
beto o'rourke and so what we have in
this city
what we have in the state of texas is it
is
is is a battle for the soul of our
economy
are we going to be capitalists are we
going to be socialists we've seen the
socialist agenda
through bachelor or wark and julian
castro and people like that
texas must prevail we must keep texas
capitalism let me tell you this last
thing that democrats will not
and that is it's been capitalism not
socialism
that's listed more lifted more people
out of poverty than all of the socialist
programs in the history of the world
we're not going to let the soldiers take
over now
i'll say this about texas and it's so
telling
if you take a u-haul from california to
texas
it's about 2 500 bucks if you take it
from texas back to california
it's about 300 you're doing u-haul a
favor
now i know texas is very inclusive but
if people are going to come from
california new york to texas
i think it's fair to say they need to
leave their liberal policies that
destroyed their states behind
fair fair enough governor we always love
having you thank you for thank you sean
thank you very much all right when we
come back we'll return uh a few other
questions for president trump non-water
related as we continue our town hall
thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else